the Battle of Winterfell everybody's
talking about it it was one of the most
extensive battle scenes ever filmed
that's including going to the movies
going to the cinema to Luke on
television how long did it take to shoot
that well the night show portion of it
was like fifty five nights so that's 11
weeks Monday through Friday it's 11
weeks early now you have to remember
normal high quality television would not
if you're lucky you get 11 days to shoot
an arrow to shoot a full you know we're
full episode and this was 11 weeks of
that and there was additional
photography after that as well and it
was just it was astonishing and listen I
shelled out the ensemble nature of the
show the actors come in they go out they
do their bit and they look heroic the
actual heroes of this were the crew were
the prop people to make up costume who
are on every night in freezing cold
weather and they they are the real
heroes of the Battle of winter yeah you
started actually in very cold condition
how did that compare the other one of
the other great battles is the Battle of
the bastards and I'm curious how those
two battles compared obviously more time
with stent on the Battle of Winterfell
but battled the bastards was just this
epic epic Nikol and it was a picnic
quickly you get angry there's nothing
compared to it yeah that was we felt
that for a bit five weeks that was a
twenty minute sequence and the Battle of
Winterfell I think is the longest battle
that has ever been shown and I think
it's longer than the helms deep thing
and in in Lord of the Rings and all that
it was it was like constant battle from
beginning to end which is extraordinary
and incredibly difficult to direct
because of that with that level of
action and violence and and all that's
all that stuff Miguel supports Nikki a
director that has to be congratulated
and done a brilliant job how did you how
do you feel about the yeah go ahead give
him a hand why not do also did the
bottle of the bastards as well as you do
the battle the Basinger he's the battle
expert